- ยินดีต้อนรับกลับมาสู่ Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation
ผมชื่อ John Watrous และเป็นผู้อำนวยการด้านเทคนิค
ของ IBM Quantum Education
นี่คือบทเรียนที่สามของซีรีส์นี้ ในสองบทเรียนแรก เราพูดถึงพื้นฐาน
ของข้อมูลควอนตัม
เริ่มจากระบบเดี่ยวที่อยู่โดดเดี่ยว แล้วก็ระบบหลายระบบ
เรายังพูดถึงการวัดแบบ
standard basis และการดำเนินการแบบยูนิทารีทั้งในกรณี
ระบบเดี่ยวและหลายระบบ
ในบทเรียนนี้ เราจะแนะนำ
quantum circuit model ซึ่งให้วิธีมาตรฐานในการอธิบายการคำนวณควอนตัม
และเราก็ใช้ quantum circuit เพื่ออธิบายโปรโตคอลควอนตัมและปฏิสัมพันธ์ประเภทอื่นๆ ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับอุปกรณ์ควอนตัมหลายตัวได้ด้วย
นอกจาก quantum circuit แล้ว เราจะพูดถึง
แนวคิดทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่สำคัญบางอย่างที่เกี่ยวข้องกับข้อมูลควอนตัม
และเราจะใช้มันเพื่อสังเกต
ข้อจำกัดพื้นฐานบางอย่างของข้อมูลควอนตัมและสิ่งที่เราทำได้ด้วย quantum circuit
นั่นจะเตรียมเราได้ดีสำหรับ
บทเรียนถัดไปหลังจากนี้ ที่เราจะเห็นตัวอย่าง
ที่สำคัญมากบางอย่าง และนั่นจะเป็นการสรุป
หน่วยแรกของซีรีส์
เกี่ยวกับพื้นฐานของข้อมูลควอนตัม
นี่คือภาพรวมของบทเรียน เราจะเริ่มด้วย quantum circuit model และดูว่ามันทำงานยังไง
จากนั้นเราจะพูดถึง
แนวคิดที่สำคัญมากอย่าง inner product รวมถึง orthonormality และ projection
ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ inner product เราไม่ได้พูดถึงเรื่องพวกนี้
ในสองบทเรียนแรก เพราะเราไม่จำเป็นต้องใช้จริงๆ
แต่ตอนนี้เราต้องใช้แล้ว
Inner product ให้เครื่องมือ
ทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่เราขาดไม่ได้เลย
เราจะไปไม่ไกลเลยในการทำความเข้าใจข้อมูลควอนตัมและ
การคำนวณโดยไม่มี inner product
และในส่วนที่สามของบทเรียน เราจะดู
ข้อจำกัดที่สำคัญบางอย่างของข้อมูลควอนตัม
สิ่งที่เราอยากทำจริงๆ คือสำรวจสิ่ง
ที่น่าสนใจที่เราทำได้กับข้อมูลควอนตัม แต่เพื่อจะทำสิ่งนี้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
เราต้องรู้ถึงบางสิ่ง
ที่เราทำไม่ได้
โดยเฉพาะ เราจะพูดถึง
แนวคิดเรื่อง global phase และทำไม global phase ถึงไม่มีผล
เราจะเห็นข้อความของ
ทฤษฎีบท no-cloning ที่บอกว่าสถานะควอนตัมไม่สามารถถูกคัดลอกได้โดยทั่วไป และเราจะเห็นว่าสถานะควอนตัมสองสถานะ
ไม่สามารถถูกแยกแยะ
ได้อย่างสมบูรณ์แบบ เว้นแต่ว่ามันจะ orthogonal ซึ่งเป็นข้อจำกัด
พื้นฐานที่ควรรู้ไว้
หัวข้อแรกของบทเรียน
คือ quantum circuit model ซึ่งเป็นแบบจำลองการคำนวณ
ที่ให้วิธีแก่เรา
ในการอธิบายการคำนวณควอนตัม
Quantum circuit model
อิงจากแนวคิดทั่วไปกว่าในวิทยาการคอมพิวเตอร์เรื่อง circuit และเราสามารถนิยามแบบจำลอง
การคำนวณได้หลายแบบ
อิงจากแนวคิดทั่วไปนี้
แนวคิดพื้นฐานคือ
circuit ประกอบด้วยสาย (wire) ที่ส่งข้อมูล และ gate ที่แทนการดำเนินการ
ที่ใช้กับข้อมูล
ที่ส่งผ่านสายเหล่านั้น
คำว่า circuit จริงๆ แล้ว
เป็นชื่อที่แปลกๆ สำหรับแบบจำลองประเภทนี้
เพราะคำว่า circuit
มักหมายถึง
เส้นทางวงกลมบางอย่าง
แต่เวลาเราพูดถึง circuit
ในฐานะแบบจำลองการคำนวณ เรามักพูดถึง
circuit แบบไม่มีวงจร (acyclic)
ที่ไม่อนุญาตให้มีเส้นทางวงกลม
ให้ชัดเจนกว่านี้ สำหรับ
จุดประสงค์ของซีรีส์นี้ เราจะกำหนดว่า
ข้อมูลไหลจากซ้ายไปขวาเสมอใน circuit ทุกอัน
ดังนั้นถ้าอยากจะคิด
เราสามารถคิดว่า circuit อธิบายลำดับของการดำเนินการที่เวลาไปจากซ้ายไปขวา
นี่คือตัวอย่างของ Boolean circuit ที่สายส่งค่า
ไบนารี ศูนย์หรือหนึ่ง
และ gate แทน
การดำเนินการตรรกะแบบ Boolean
สายแทนด้วยเส้น และเรามีบิตอินพุตสองตัว
ที่ชื่อ X กับ Y
และถ้าเราอยากรู้ว่า
circuit ทำอะไรกับอินพุตที่เลือก เราก็ส่งค่าไปตาม
สายจากซ้ายไปขวา
ขึ้นอยู่กับการกระทำ
ที่ gate มีต่อค่าที่
ส่งผ่านสาย
ตัวอย่างเช่น เราสามารถ
ดูว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อเราเริ่มด้วยสายอินพุตบนตั้งค่าเป็นหนึ่ง และสายอินพุตล่าง
ตั้งค่าเป็นศูนย์
สายอินพุตสองเส้นนี้นำ
เข้าไปที่จุดสองจุดนี้ตรงนี้ ซึ่งแทนการดำเนินการ fan-out หมายความว่าค่าถูกคัดลอก
เพื่อให้ส่งต่อไปตาม
สายหลายเส้นได้
ดังนั้นถ้าเราทำแบบนี้
สายสองเส้นนี้จะมีค่าหนึ่ง เหมือนกับเส้นนี้ และสายสองเส้นนี้จะมีค่าศูนย์
เหมือนกับเส้นนี้
ตรงนี้เรามี NOT gate ซึ่ง
แสดงด้วยสัญลักษณ์ของการปฏิเสธตรรกะ ดังนั้น
ค่าที่ออกมาคือศูนย์
ซึ่งเป็นการปฏิเสธตรรกะของหนึ่ง และเช่นเดียวกัน ค่า
ที่ออกจาก gate นี้คือหนึ่ง ซึ่งเป็น
การปฏิเสธตรรกะของศูนย์
gate สองตัวนี้คือ AND gate
gate นี้คือ OR gate และถ้าเราดำเนินต่อ
และส่งค่าไป
ผ่าน circuit โดยประเมิน
gate อย่างเหมาะสม เราจะเห็นว่าค่าสุดท้าย
บนสายนี้ตรงนี้คือหนึ่ง
ดังนั้น circuit ทั้งหมดอธิบาย
ลำดับของการดำเนินการที่ประกอบกันตามที่รูปแสดง และเราได้ฟังก์ชัน
จากสองบิตเป็นหนึ่งบิต
ในกรณีนี้ แต่โดยทั่วไป อาจมีจำนวนบิตอินพุต
และเอาต์พุตเท่าไหร่ก็ได้
Circuit นี้บังเอิญคำนวณ exclusive OR ของบิตอินพุตสองตัว ดังนั้นเอาต์พุตเป็นหนึ่ง
ก็ต่อเมื่อ
บิตอินพุตหนึ่งในสองตัวถูกตั้งเป็นหนึ่ง และอีกตัวถูกตั้งเป็นศูนย์ แต่นั่นไม่สำคัญ
จริงๆ มันแค่เป็นตัวอย่าง
เป็นข้อเท็จจริงพื้นฐานเกี่ยวกับ Boolean circuit ว่าฟังก์ชันใดๆ จากจำนวนบิตเท่าไหร่ก็ได้ไปยังจำนวนบิตเท่าไหร่ก็ได้ สามารถคำนวณได้
ด้วย Boolean circuit บางอัน แม้ว่าบางทีอาจ
ต้องใช้ circuit ขนาดใหญ่มากในการคำนวณฟังก์ชัน
ที่เราสนใจ
มีรูปแบบอื่นๆ ที่ใช้
ในการอธิบาย circuit
ตัวอย่างเช่น รูปนี้
แทน circuit เดียวกันกับที่เรามีก่อนหน้า โดยใช้รูปแบบที่อาจจะปกติกว่า
ในวิศวกรรมไฟฟ้า ที่มีข้อตกลงสำหรับรูปร่างที่แทน gate ต่างๆ
เราจะไม่ใช้
รูปแบบนี้ แต่เราจะแนะนำ
สัญลักษณ์ของเราเองสำหรับ quantum gate ต่างๆ เช่น Hadamard gate,
Controlled NOT gate,
Toffoli gate และอื่นๆ
แค่เกร็ดเล็กน้อย ตรงนี้เราเห็นที่มา
ของคำว่า circuit
ในบริบทของวิศวกรรมไฟฟ้า เป็นเรื่องธรรมชาติมากที่จะ
คิดถึงกระแสไฟฟ้าที่วนผ่าน circuit
แต่ในซีรีส์นี้เราไม่ได้
พูดถึงกระแสไฟฟ้าที่เคลื่อนผ่าน circuit เราพูดถึงข้อมูล
ที่เคลื่อนผ่าน circuit
และอีกครั้ง สำหรับเรา มันจะเป็นแบบ acyclic เสมอ โดยข้อมูล
เคลื่อนจากซ้ายไปขวา
นี่คือตัวอย่างอีกแบบของ
circuit ประเภทอื่นที่เรียกว่า arithmetic circuit
คราวนี้สายเก็บตัวเลขและ gate แทน
การดำเนินการทางคณิตศาสตร์ เช่น การบวกและการคูณ
ตรงนี้เห็นตัวอย่างของ
arithmetic circuit ได้
ไม่สำคัญสำหรับ
บทเรียนนี้ว่ามันทำอะไร มันแค่ตัวอย่างที่
ต้องการสื่อว่ามี
แนวคิดเรื่อง circuit หลายแบบ
เราก็คิดถึง
circuit ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับความสุ่มได้ด้วย เช่น ที่ gate แทน
การดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็น และถ้าอยากจะ
ก็อาจนั่งคิดแบบจำลองการคำนวณใหม่ๆ ที่อิงจากแนวคิดเรื่อง circuit ได้ทั้งวันเลย
ใน quantum circuit model
สายแทน qubit และ gate แทนทั้งการดำเนินการยูนิทารีและการวัด
นี่คือตัวอย่างง่ายๆ
ของ quantum circuit
มี qubit เดียวใน circuit นี้ ซึ่งแทนด้วย
เส้นแนวนอน และ gate ซึ่งแสดงด้วย
สี่เหลี่ยม
แทนการดำเนินการยูนิทารีที่ใช้กับ qubit นี้
ดังนั้นไม่มีการวัด
ในตัวอย่างนี้
ถ้าเราอยากตั้งชื่อ
qubit เช่น X เราสามารถระบุในไดอะแกรมโดยใส่ X ตรงนี้
นั่นเป็นทางเลือก
เหมือนกับที่เรามีสำหรับ Boolean circuit เมื่อสักครู่ เราสามารถคิดว่า circuit นี้
แทนลำดับของการดำเนินการที่เวลา
ไปจากซ้ายไปขวา
เราเริ่มจาก X
ใช้ gate แรก ซึ่งคือ Hadamard gate
ตามด้วย S gate
แล้วก็ Hadamard
gate อีกตัว และสุดท้าย T gate
เราเห็นการดำเนินการเหล่านี้
ตอนท้ายบทเรียนที่หนึ่ง และตรงนี้เห็น
คำอธิบายเป็นเมทริกซ์ของมัน
ดังนั้นเมื่อเราทำ
สี่การดำเนินการนี้ตามลำดับ หมายถึง H ก่อน แล้ว
S แล้ว H อีกครั้ง แล้ว T
การดำเนินการรวมให้ผลลัพธ์เป็น
ผลคูณนี้ตรงนี้ โดยจำไว้ว่าลำดับ
จะกลับกัน
อย่างที่เราพูดในบทเรียนที่หนึ่ง ถ้าเราคูณเมทริกซ์ เราจะได้เมทริกซ์นี้ตรงนี้
และการกระทำของ
circuit ต่อ qubit X อธิบายได้ด้วยเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีนี้
บางทีเราอยากระบุชัดเจนในไดอะแกรม quantum circuit
ว่าอินพุตที่เราใส่เข้าไปคืออะไร และเราทำได้ตามที่เห็นตรงนี้
ในกรณีนี้ เราใส่
Ket 0 เข้าไปใน circuit
นั่นค่อนข้างปกติ เรามักถือว่า Ket 0 เป็น
สถานะเริ่มต้นของ qubit แต่ไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็นแบบนั้น
เราก็พิจารณา
ใช้ circuit กับสถานะอื่นได้
ถ้าเราเลือก เราก็สามารถ
ระบุสถานะเอาต์พุตที่ได้แบบนี้
นี่คืออีกตัวอย่างที่
คราวนี้เรามี qubit สองตัวชื่อ X และ Y ตามที่
เห็นในไดอะแกรม
ตรงนี้เรามี Hadamard gate ที่ใช้กับ qubit Y ตามด้วย gate ที่แสดงด้วย
สัญลักษณ์ตรงนี้
ซึ่งคือ Controlled NOT gate เราพูดถึง
Controlled NOT operation ในบทเรียนที่แล้ว
และตรงนี้ในไดอะแกรมเรา
เห็นว่า control qubit คือ Y ซึ่งแสดงด้วย
วงกลมเล็กทึบ
และ target qubit คือ X ซึ่งแสดงด้วยวงกลมใหญ่ที่มีเครื่องหมายบวกอยู่ข้างใน
มันดูเหมือน
สัญลักษณ์ของ exclusive OR เลยก็สมเหตุสมผล
ลองนึกว่าสถานะแบบ
คลาสสิกที่เก็บใน Y ถูก XOR ไปที่ qubit X
และเพื่อความชัดเจน นี่คือไดอะแกรมที่
แสดงการกระทำของ gate นี้ต่อสถานะ standard basis
โดยเราสมมติว่า A
กับ B เป็นค่าไบนารี
สำหรับสถานะอื่น การกระทำกำหนดโดย
ความเป็นเชิงเส้นตามปกติ
ทีนี้ ก่อนจะไปต่อ มันจะเป็นประโยชน์ที่จะ
ระบุข้อตกลงที่เราจะใช้เกี่ยวกับการเรียงลำดับ qubit อย่างชัดเจน
ในไดอะแกรม quantum circuit แบบนี้
และข้อตกลงคือ
การเรียงจากล่างขึ้นบนในไดอะแกรม quantum circuit เทียบเท่ากับการเรียงจากซ้ายไปขวา
เหมือนในทูเพิลหรือเทนเซอร์โปรดักต์
นั่นคือข้อตกลงที่เรา
จะใช้ในซีรีส์นี้ และเป็นข้อตกลงเดียวกัน
ที่ใช้ใน Qiskit
ดังนั้นสำหรับ circuit นี้ตรงนี้ เราคิดว่ามัน
กระทำต่อคู่ของ qubit X, Y
X มาก่อนเพราะอยู่ด้านล่าง และ Y มาหลังหรือเป็นตัวที่สองในกรณีนี้ เพราะอยู่ด้านบน
วิธีที่เราคิดภาพ
ในกรณีที่ช่วยได้ คือลองจินตนาการว่าหมุน
circuit นี้ตามเข็มนาฬิกาเพื่อให้อินพุตอยู่ด้านบน
และเอาต์พุตอยู่ด้านล่าง แล้วลำดับของ
qubit จะถูกต้อง
บางทีลำดับนี้ทำให้คนสับสน ดังนั้นจำ
ข้อตกลงนี้ไว้ให้ดี
ดังนั้นเมื่อเราคิดถึงการกระทำที่ circuit นี้อธิบาย สิ่งที่เรามีก่อนคือ
Hadamard gate ที่ใช้กับ Y
แล้วก็ Controlled NOT
gate บน qubit สองตัว โดย Y เป็น control
และ X เป็น target
ถ้าเราอยากเขียนเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีที่อธิบายการกระทำรวม
ของ gate สองตัวนี้ เราก็ทำได้
ก่อนอื่น เราพิจารณา Hadamard gate บน Y
เราใช้ Hadamard gate กับ Y และไม่ทำอะไรกับ X ซึ่งเทียบเท่ากับ
การดำเนินการ identity บน X
ดังนั้นการกระทำของ Hadamard gate บน qubit ทั้งสองรวมกัน
ให้ผลเป็นเทนเซอร์โปรดักต์ของเมทริกซ์ identity กับ
เมทริกซ์ที่แทน
Hadamard operation บน Y
มันดูแบบนี้ โดยจำข้อตกลง
ของเราว่า X มาก่อนและ Y มาที่สอง ดังนั้นเป็น
identity เทนเซอร์กับ H
แล้วเราใช้
Controlled NOT operation ซึ่งมีการแทน
เมทริกซ์แบบนี้ และอีกครั้ง นั่นสอดคล้องกับข้อตกลงของเรา
qubit ที่สอง Y เป็น control และ qubit แรก X เป็น target
อย่าลังเลที่จะหยุดวิดีโอและตรวจสอบว่ามันสมเหตุสมผล แล้วผมจะเลิกเตือนเรื่องนี้
สามารถหยุดวิดีโอเหล่านี้ ย้อนกลับไปดูส่วนต่างๆ
กี่ครั้งก็ได้ตามต้องการ ปรับความเร็วเล่นถ้าอยากจะ ใช้มันในแบบ
ที่เหมาะกับตัวเองที่สุด
อย่างไรก็ตาม เมื่อเราประกอบ
สองการดำเนินการเข้าด้วยกัน การกระทำรวมอธิบาย
ด้วยผลคูณนี้ตรงนี้
และเมทริกซ์สองตัวนี้
คูณในลำดับนี้เพราะ Hadamard ทำก่อนและ Controlled NOT
ทำที่สอง
และอีกครั้ง นี่สอดคล้อง
กับที่เราพูดในบทเรียนที่หนึ่ง ที่ลำดับ
จะกลับกัน
ถ้าเราคูณเมทริกซ์ เราจะได้เมทริกซ์นี้ตรงนี้
และเราสามารถอ่านจากเมทริกซ์นี้ว่า circuit ทำอะไรกับ
สถานะ standard basis
ถ้าเรารัน circuit ด้วยอินพุต 0, 0 หมายถึง Ket 0 สำหรับ qubit แรก, Ket 0 สำหรับ qubit ที่สอง
ผลลัพธ์คือสถานะ Bell Phi+ ซึ่งเราเห็นได้จาก
คอลัมน์แรกของเมทริกซ์
ถ้าเราใส่ 0, 1 เราจะได้สถานะ Phi- หนึ่งศูนย์ให้เราสถานะ Psi+
และ 1, 1 ให้เราไม่ใช่ Psi- แต่เป็น -1 คูณ Psi-
เครื่องหมายลบไม่ได้
สำคัญจริงๆ ตรงนี้ ถ้าไม่อยากให้มันอยู่ตรงนี้ ก็ทำการดำเนินการ swap
บน qubit สองตัว
เพื่อกำจัดมัน แล้วก็
จะไม่ทำลายสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นกับ standard basis state สามตัวแรก
แต่มันไม่สำคัญจริงๆ
สำหรับตัวอย่างนี้
สรุปแล้ว circuit มีการกระทำแบบนี้ตรงนี้ต่อสถานะ standard basis
เวลาคิดว่า
circuit ตัวหนึ่งทำอะไร ไม่จำเป็นต้องแปลง
เป็นเมทริกซ์แล้วคูณเข้าด้วยกัน
เราก็ตามการกระทำ
ที่ circuit มีต่อสถานะเฉพาะได้ และในหลายกรณี
นี่จะเป็นตัวเลือกที่ดีกว่า
ในตัวอย่างนี้ เราเห็นว่า circuit
ทำอะไรกับสถานะ 0, 0 โดยดูที่การกระทำของ gate
สถานะเริ่มต้น ที่
เราตั้งชื่อว่า Pi ศูนย์ตรงนี้ เพื่อหลีกเลี่ยงชื่อ
ที่จะสับสนกับสถานะ Bell คือ 0, 0
เราใช้ Hadamard gate แล้วสถานะที่ได้คือ 0+ ซึ่งเราขยายออกได้แบบนี้
แล้ว Controlled NOT operation เอาสถานะนี้ไปเป็นสถานะ Phi+ ซึ่งเราเห็นได้จากการคิด
ถึงการกระทำที่ Controlled NOT มีต่อ
สถานะ standard basis
และก็ทำเหมือนกันได้
สำหรับ standard basis state อีกสามตัว หรือ
สถานะอื่นใดก็ได้
เราก็ใส่บิตแบบคลาสสิกในไดอะแกรม quantum circuit ได้ด้วย
มันแสดงด้วย
เส้นคู่ตามที่เห็นในไดอะแกรม
นั่นคือ A กับ B เป็นบิตแบบคลาสสิก และ X กับ Y เป็น qubit
เรามี gate ยูนิทารีสองตัวเหมือนในตัวอย่างก่อนหน้า และสัญลักษณ์เหล่านี้ตรงนี้แทนการวัดแบบ standard basis
โดยเฉพาะ หลังจากการดำเนินการ
ยูนิทารีสองอันเสร็จ การวัดแบบ standard basis
ถูกทำกับ Y
และผลลัพธ์ถูกเขียนทับ
ไปที่บิตแบบคลาสสิก B และเช่นเดียวกัน X ถูกวัดและผลลัพธ์ถูกเขียนไปที่บิต A
ตรงนี้เห็นว่า qubit X กับ Y ยังดำเนินต่อไปหลังจากถูกวัด
แต่ค่อนข้างปกติ
ที่เราไม่ค่อยสนใจ qubit
หลังจากถูกวัดแล้ว
บางทีเราสนใจแค่
ผลลัพธ์การวัด และในกรณีแบบนั้น เราใช้รูปแบบย่อ
ที่เห็นตรงนี้
ที่การวัดมี qubit เข้ามาและบิตแบบคลาสสิกออกไป
ความเข้าใจตรงนี้คือ
เมื่อ qubit ถูกวัดแล้ว มันก็ถูกทิ้งหรือถูกเพิกเฉย และผลลัพธ์การวัด
แบบคลาสสิกถูกส่งต่อ
ทีนี้ เมื่อซีรีส์ดำเนินไป เราจะเห็น
ตัวอย่างของ quantum circuit มากมาย และมักจะ
ซับซ้อนกว่าตัวอย่าง
ง่ายๆ ที่เราเพิ่งเห็นมากนัก
อย่างที่พูดก่อนหน้า สัญลักษณ์ต่างๆ ใช้
สำหรับ gate ต่างๆ
Gate qubit เดี่ยวมัก
เขียนเป็นสี่เหลี่ยมพร้อมตัวอักษรที่บอกว่า
เป็นการดำเนินการอะไร
บางที gate เหล่านี้
ถูกแยกสีเพื่อหมายถึงสิ่งต่างๆ แต่
เราจะข้ามไปก่อน
เราเห็น
Controlled NOT gate ไปแล้ว
Swap gate แสดง
ตามที่เห็นตรงนี้ และ Toffoli gate กับ Fredkin gate
แสดงตามที่เห็นตรงนี้
จำไว้ว่า Toffoli gate คือ controlled Controlled NOT gate และ Fredkin gate คือ
controlled swap gate
ดังนั้นสัญลักษณ์เหล่านี้
สอดคล้องกับแนวคิดที่ว่า control qubit
แสดงด้วยวงกลมทึบพร้อมเส้นเชื่อมไปที่
gate ที่มันควบคุม
โดยทั่วไป controlled qubit
ไม่จำเป็นต้องอยู่ด้านบน และ gate เหล่านี้ไม่จำเป็น
ต้องกระทำบน qubit ที่อยู่ติดกัน หมายความว่า gate เหล่านี้
สามารถยืดข้าม
qubit อื่นที่มันไม่ได้กระทำ และเราจะเห็นสิ่งนั้น
เกิดขึ้นในบทเรียนต่อๆ ไป
อีกสิ่งหนึ่งที่เรามักทำเมื่อใช้ quantum circuit model คือมองการดำเนินการยูนิทารีใดๆ
บน qubit จำนวนเท่าไหร่ก็ได้
เป็นเหมือน gate เดี่ยวตามที่เห็นตรงนี้
แค่วาดสี่เหลี่ยมผืนผ้าพร้อมป้ายกำกับที่ตรงกับ
การดำเนินการยูนิทารีที่ต้องการ
ในกรณีนี้เป็น
การดำเนินการยูนิทารี U บางอัน
แน่นอน เราไม่รู้
ว่า U คืออะไรจากไดอะแกรม เราต้องสมมติว่า
U ถูกนิยามไว้แล้ว หรือว่าเรากำลังพิจารณา
การดำเนินการยูนิทารี U ใดๆ
ก็ได้ อาจเป็นเช่น
เราแค่อยากคิดว่า U เป็น subroutine
เพื่อความชัดเจน
เราก็ใช้สัญลักษณ์
ที่เห็นตรงนี้สำหรับ controlled U operation
โดย control qubit แสดงด้วยวงกลมทึบ
เหมือนที่เรามีก่อนหน้า
นั่นคือการแนะนำสั้นๆ
เกี่ยวกับ quantum circuit model และอย่างที่บอก เราจะเห็นตัวอย่าง
ของ quantum circuit อีกเยอะ
เมื่อเราดำเนินต่อในซีรีส์
ในส่วนถัดไปของบทเรียน เราจะมา
ดู inner product, orthonormality และ projection ซึ่งเป็นแนวคิดที่สำคัญมาก
ในข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณ
เราจะเริ่มด้วย inner product
จำได้ว่าเมื่อเรา
ใช้สัญลักษณ์ Dirac Ket คือเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์
และ Bra คือเวกเตอร์แถว
และโดยเฉพาะ
เวกเตอร์ Bra ที่สอดคล้องกับเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ที่ให้มา คือสังยุคทรานสโพส
ของเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์นั้น
สำหรับเวกเตอร์ตรงนี้ เราได้ Bra ที่สอดคล้องโดยทรานสโพสเวกเตอร์
เหมือนกับมันเป็นเมทริกซ์
ซึ่งก็คือวางมันตะแคง แล้วก็หาสังยุคเชิงซ้อนของแต่ละสมาชิก
ทีนี้ สมมติว่าเรามี Ket สองตัวที่มีจำนวนสมาชิกเท่ากันแบบนี้
ถ้าเราสร้าง bracket นี้ตรงนี้ ซึ่งหมายความว่า
เราคูณ Bra กับ Ket
เหมือนกับมันเป็นเมทริกซ์
เราก็จะได้นิพจน์นี้
ที่เห็นตรงนี้ ซึ่งเป็นสเกลาร์ หรือพูด
อีกอย่างคือจำนวนเชิงซ้อน
ค่านี้เรียกว่า inner
product ของเวกเตอร์สองตัวนี้
เราก็คิดถึง inner product ในรูปของเวกเตอร์
ที่อยู่ในรูปแบบตรงนี้ได้ โดยเวกเตอร์ถูกแสดง
เป็นผลรวมเชิงเส้น
ของเวกเตอร์ standard basis
Inner product ของเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้นิยามแบบเดียวกับ
ก่อนหน้า Bra Psi คูณ Ket Phi ซึ่งเราแสดง
เป็นผลคูณแบบนี้
และถ้าเราคำนวณแล้วทำให้ง่าย เราเหลือนิพจน์นี้ตรงนี้สำหรับ inner product ซึ่งคล้ายกับที่เรามีก่อนหน้า
ยกเว้นคราวนี้เรา
หาผลรวมตามสมาชิกในเซตสถานะแบบคลาสสิก ซึ่งคือ sigma ในกรณีนี้
นี่คือตัวอย่างที่ตั้งใจให้ภาพเรขาคณิตของ
inner product ทำงานยังไง
ตรงนี้ผมวาดวงกลม
ในปริภูมิสองมิติที่สอดคล้องกับ qubit และตราบใดที่เราจำกัดความสนใจ
ไปที่เวกเตอร์ที่มีสมาชิกเป็นจำนวนจริง เราสามารถวาดมันเป็นจุดบนระนาบนี้
ให้ Phi เป็น
เวกเตอร์ตรงนี้
มันเป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย ซึ่งเห็นได้จาก
การคำนวณนอร์มแบบยูคลิด และนั่นคือสิ่งที่วงกลมนี้แทน
มันคือเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วยทั้งหมด
ที่มีสมาชิกเป็นจำนวนจริง
ให้ Psi เป็น
เวกเตอร์ตรงนี้ด้วย ซึ่งก็เป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วยเช่นกัน
มันคือสถานะลบนั่นเอง แต่ตรงนี้เราเรียกมันว่า Psi
ถ้าเราคำนวณ inner
product ของเวกเตอร์สองตัวนี้ เราได้หนึ่งลบรากที่สองของสามส่วนสองคูณรากสอง
ซึ่งบังเอิญเป็นประมาณ -1/4
ค่าของ inner product นี้เท่ากับโคไซน์ของมุม
ระหว่างเวกเตอร์สองตัว ซึ่งเห็นได้ตรงนี้ในรูป
นั่นเป็นสิ่งที่
เป็นจริงโดยทั่วไปสำหรับเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย ถ้าเรามีเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วยสองตัวและมันมีสมาชิกเป็นจำนวนจริง
inner product ระหว่างมันก็เท่ากับโคไซน์ของ
มุมระหว่างมัน
โดยเฉพาะ ถ้า inner
product เท่ากับศูนย์ เหมือนในตัวอย่างนี้ ที่เราเปลี่ยน Psi ให้เป็น
สถานะตรงนี้
เวกเตอร์สองตัวต้อง
ทำมุม 90 องศาต่อกัน
ทั้งหมดนี้สามารถขยายไป
เวกเตอร์ในมิติใดก็ได้ อย่างไรก็ตาม ตราบใดที่
สมาชิกเป็นจำนวนจริง ไม่ใช่แค่สำหรับเวกเตอร์สองมิติ
ถ้าเรามีสมาชิกเป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อน ภาพจะใช้ไม่ได้
อีกต่อไป แต่ถึงอย่างนั้น inner product ก็
มีประโยชน์เท่าเดิมอย่างที่เราจะเห็น
Inner product มี
คุณสมบัติที่สำคัญมากบางอย่าง และเราจะใช้เวลาสักครู่สังเกตคุณสมบัติเหล่านั้น
อันแรกคือความเชื่อมโยง
ระหว่าง inner product กับนอร์มแบบยูคลิด
ถ้าเราหา inner product
ของเวกเตอร์ใดๆ กับตัวมันเอง เราจะได้นอร์มแบบยูคลิดกำลังสอง
ดังนั้นเราก็พูดได้อีกอย่างว่านอร์มแบบยูคลิดของเวกเตอร์เท่ากับรากที่สอง
ของ inner product
ของเวกเตอร์นั้นกับตัวมันเอง นี่ไม่ใช่เรื่องบังเอิญ นี่
คือความเชื่อมโยงพื้นฐาน และตรงนี้เราเห็นว่าถ้าเราไม่มี
สังยุคเชิงซ้อนในนิยามของ inner product นิพจน์นี้
ก็จะไม่เป็นจริงอีกต่อไป และเราก็จะไม่มีแนวคิดที่มีประโยชน์แบบนี้
พร้อมความเชื่อมโยงพื้นฐาน
กับนอร์มแบบยูคลิด
ถัดมา inner product
เป็นแบบสมมาตรสังยุค หมายความว่าถ้าเราสลับ
ลำดับของอาร์กิวเมนต์สองตัว ค่าที่ได้สำหรับ inner product จะถูกหาสังยุค
นั่นแสดงด้วย
สมการตรงนี้ และค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมาที่จะเห็นว่าทำไมมันเป็นแบบนี้ สำหรับนิพจน์สองอัน
ของ inner product ของเวกเตอร์สองตัวในสองลำดับที่เป็นไปได้
Inner product เป็นเชิงเส้น
ในอาร์กิวเมนต์ที่สอง โดยเฉพาะ ถ้าเรานิยามเวกเตอร์ Phi เป็นผลรวมเชิงเส้น
ของเวกเตอร์สองตัว
Phi หนึ่งและ Phi สอง inner product ของ
เวกเตอร์ Psi ใดๆ กับ Phi ก็เป็นผลรวมเชิงเส้นเดียวกัน
ของ inner product สองตัว
และนี่ตามมาค่อนข้าง
ตรงจากข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่าการคูณเมทริกซ์เป็นเชิงเส้น
และเรายังมีว่า inner
product เป็นเชิงเส้นแบบสังยุคในอาร์กิวเมนต์แรก ซึ่งเห็นได้ตรงนี้
ถ้า Psi เป็นผลรวม
เชิงเส้นของเวกเตอร์ ถ้าเราหา inner
product ของ Psi กับ Phi
Bra Psi จะกลายเป็นเวกเตอร์ตรงนี้ ที่เราหา
สังยุคเชิงซ้อนของ beta หนึ่งและ beta สอง
ดังนั้นนี่คือผลลัพธ์ และนั่นคือสิ่งที่
ความเป็นเชิงเส้นแบบสังยุคหมายถึง
และคุณสมบัติสุดท้ายของ inner product ที่อยากพูดถึงคือ
อสมการ Cauchy-Schwarz ที่มีประโยชน์อย่างเหลือเชื่อ
สำหรับเวกเตอร์ Psi และ Phi ใดๆ ค่าสัมบูรณ์ของ inner product จะไม่มีทางมากกว่าผลคูณ
ของนอร์มแบบยูคลิด
ของเวกเตอร์สองตัว และยิ่งไปกว่านั้น ทางเดียวที่
สองข้างของอสมการจะเท่ากันคือถ้าเวกเตอร์
สองตัวไม่เป็นอิสระเชิงเส้น
หมายความว่าตัวหนึ่งเท่ากับสเกลาร์คูณอีกตัว
นี่เป็นจริงๆ แล้ว
อสมการที่ใช้กันมากที่สุดอันหนึ่งในคณิตศาสตร์ทั้งหมด และ
เราใช้มันซ้ำแล้วซ้ำเล่าเมื่อพูดถึง
ข้อมูลควอนตัม
ดังนั้นรู้ไว้ดีมาก
ถัดไป เราจะพูดถึง
แนวคิดเรื่อง orthogonality และ orthonormality ที่
เชื่อมโยงกับ inner product
และโดยเฉพาะ กับ
inner product ของเวกเตอร์ที่เท่ากับศูนย์
ให้ชัดเจน ถ้าเรามี
เวกเตอร์สองตัว Psi และ Phi เราบอกว่ามันเป็น orthogonal
ถ้า inner product ของมัน
เท่ากับศูนย์ และวิธีที่เราคิด
ถึงเวกเตอร์ orthogonal ตามสัญชาตญาณคือมัน
ตั้งฉากกัน
หรืออีกอย่าง มัน
ตั้งฉากกัน (perpendicular)
คนบางทีใช้คำว่า orthogonal เพื่ออ้างถึงสิ่งที่
ไม่เกี่ยวข้องกัน เช่นพูดว่าเรื่องหนึ่ง
orthogonal กับอีกเรื่อง
แต่นั่นชัดเจนว่าค่อนข้างไม่เป็นทางการ
และไม่มีความหมายทางคณิตศาสตร์จริงๆ แต่ความเชื่อมโยงชัดเจนถ้าคิดถึงเวกเตอร์ orthogonal
ว่าชี้ไป
ไม่ใช่ทิศตรงข้ามกัน แต่ทิศที่ต่างกันอย่างสิ้นเชิง เช่นเหนือกับตะวันตก
ถ้าเรามีเซตของเวกเตอร์ เราบอกว่าเซตนั้นเป็น orthogonal set ถ้าเวกเตอร์สองตัวที่ต่างกันใดๆ
ที่เลือกจากเซตนั้น
จำเป็นต้อง orthogonal ต่อกัน ซึ่งแสดง
ได้ตามที่เห็นตรงนี้
Orthonormal set คือ
orthogonal set ของเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย
เวกเตอร์ใน orthogonal
set ไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย และจริงๆ แล้วก็มี
เวกเตอร์ศูนย์
เป็นสมาชิกของ orthogonal set ได้ แต่ใน orthonormal set เวกเตอร์ทุกตัวต้องเป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย
นอกเหนือจาก
ข้อกำหนดว่าเซตนั้นเป็น orthogonal set
จากสิ่งที่เรารู้เกี่ยวกับความสัมพันธ์ระหว่าง inner product
กับนอร์มแบบยูคลิด เราแสดงเงื่อนไข
นี้ได้อย่างกระชับ
ตามที่เห็นตรงนี้
และสุดท้าย orthonormal basis ก็คือ orthonormal
set ที่เป็นฐานของปริภูมิเวกเตอร์
ที่เราพูดถึง
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเราเอา
classical state set sigma ใดๆ แล้วคิดถึงเซตของ
เวกเตอร์ standard basis ทั้งหมด
เราเห็นว่านี่เป็น orthonormal set และจริงๆ แล้วเป็น orthonormal basis ของปริภูมิเวกเตอร์ทั้งหมดที่สมาชิกสอดคล้องกับ
classical state set sigma นี้
นี่คือเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วยทั้งหมดและ
มัน orthogonal กันเป็นคู่ ดังนั้นเป็น orthonormal set
และเพราะเป็นฐานด้วย เราจึงได้ว่ามันเป็น orthonormal basis
Orthonormal set เป็น
อิสระเชิงเส้นเสมออย่างไรก็ตาม ดังนั้นทุกครั้งที่
มี orthonormal set มันจะเป็น orthonormal
basis ของ subspace บางอันเสมอ
แต่ในกรณีนี้ เรามีฐานสำหรับปริภูมิทั้งหมดที่เราทำงานอยู่
อีกตัวอย่างคือเซตที่
ประกอบด้วย Ket+ และ Ket-
เวกเตอร์สองตัวนี้ orthogonal กัน inner product ของมันเท่ากับศูนย์
และมันเป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วยทั้งคู่ และ span
ปริภูมิสองมิติของเวกเตอร์ที่สอดคล้องกับ qubit เดียว ดังนั้นมันสร้าง orthonormal
basis ของปริภูมินั้น
อีกตัวอย่างคือ Bell basis ซึ่งเป็น orthonormal basis ของปริภูมิ
เวกเตอร์สี่มิติทั้งหมดที่สอดคล้องกับ qubit สองตัว
เซตที่ประกอบด้วย Ket 0
กับ Ket+ อีกด้านหนึ่ง ไม่ใช่ orthogonal set เพราะ inner product ระหว่าง
เวกเตอร์เหล่านี้ไม่เป็นศูนย์
มันเป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วยทั้งคู่ และนี่เป็นฐานสำหรับปริภูมิเวกเตอร์ที่สอดคล้องกับ qubit แต่เราไม่มี orthogonality
นี่คือข้อเท็จจริงที่มีประโยชน์เกี่ยวกับ orthonormal set ที่เราจะใช้เป็นครั้งคราว
สมมติว่าเรามี
orthonormal set ของเวกเตอร์ โดยเฉพาะ สมมติว่า
เรามี M เวกเตอร์ในเซตนี้ Psi หนึ่งถึง Psi M
โดยเราสมมติว่าเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้อยู่ในปริภูมิเวกเตอร์
N มิติ หรือพูดอีกอย่าง แต่ละ
เวกเตอร์มี M สมาชิก
อย่างที่พูดไปแล้ว orthonormal set เป็น
อิสระเชิงเส้นเสมอ ดังนั้น M จะมากกว่า N ไม่ได้
แต่อาจเป็นว่า M น้อยกว่า N ได้ และนั่นคือกรณีที่
เราสนใจ
และข้อเท็จจริงบอกว่า
ถ้า M น้อยกว่า N ก็สามารถ
เพิ่มเวกเตอร์เข้าไปได้เสมอ
เข้าไปในเซตที่เราเริ่มต้น เพื่อให้ได้
orthonormal basis ของปริภูมิเรา
ให้แม่นยำ ต้อง
มีเวกเตอร์ Psi M+1 จนถึง Psi N เพื่อให้คอลเลกชันทั้งหมด
สร้าง orthonormal basis
ดังนั้นเราไม่มีทาง
ต้อนตัวเองเข้ามุม ที่พูดกันก็คือ โดยการเลือก
orthonormal set ของเวกเตอร์ที่ขยายเป็น
orthonormal basis ไม่ได้
บางทีก็แค่ดู
เซตที่เริ่มต้นแล้วหาวิธีขยายเป็น orthonormal basis ได้เลย แต่ทางเลือกที่ใช้ได้เสมอ
คือใช้กระบวนการที่เรียกว่า Gram-Schmidt
orthonormalization เพื่อสร้างเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้
ผมจะไม่อธิบาย
กระบวนการนั้นในบทเรียนนี้หรือในซีรีส์นี้ เพราะรายละเอียดไม่
สำคัญสำหรับเราจริงๆ แต่แน่นอนว่าสามารถ
ไปหาดูได้ถ้าสนใจ
มันเป็นสิ่งที่
คอมพิวเตอร์ทำได้ ในกรณีที่เกี่ยวข้อง ดังนั้น
ไม่ต้องใช้ความคิดสร้างสรรค์ มันเป็นแค่กระบวนการเชิงกล
หนึ่งในเหตุผลที่
นี่เป็นข้อเท็จจริงที่มีประโยชน์มากคือเกี่ยวข้องกับความเชื่อมโยงแน่นแฟ้นระหว่าง orthonormal
bases กับเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
โดยเฉพาะ สำหรับเมทริกซ์จัตุรัส U ใดๆ เงื่อนไขสามข้อที่เห็นตรงนี้จะสมมูลกันเสมอ
หมายความว่ามัน
จริงทั้งหมดหรือเท็จทั้งหมด
เงื่อนไขแรกบอกว่า
U เป็นเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี หมายความว่าทั้ง U dagger คูณ U และ U คูณ U dagger เท่ากับ
เมทริกซ์ identity ทั้งคู่
เงื่อนไขที่สอง
บอกว่าแถวของ U สร้าง orthonormal basis
และเงื่อนไขที่สามบอกว่าคอลัมน์ของ U
สร้าง orthonormal basis
จริงๆ แล้วไม่ยากเกินไป
ที่จะเห็นว่าทำไมความสมมูลนี้เป็นจริง
เพื่อให้ง่าย มาดู
เมทริกซ์ U สามคูณสามตามที่เห็นตรงนี้ โดยสมาชิกเป็น
จำนวนเชิงซ้อนอะไรก็ได้ตามใจ
ตรงนี้ทางซ้ายผมเขียน U สังยุคทรานสโพส
ไว้เพื่อความสะดวก
ถ้าเราสร้างเวกเตอร์สามตัว
จากคอลัมน์ของ U ซึ่งตรงนี้ตั้งชื่อว่า Psi
หนึ่ง Psi สอง และ Psi สาม แล้วถ้าเราคูณ
U dagger กับ U
จะตรวจสอบได้ว่าแต่ละ
สมาชิกของผลคูณเป็น inner product ของเวกเตอร์ตามที่เห็นตรงนี้ในรูปแบบนี้
และตอนนี้เมื่อคิดถึงเงื่อนไขที่ U เป็นยูนิทารี ซึ่งสมมูลกับเมทริกซ์นี้เท่ากับเมทริกซ์ identity
จะเห็นว่ามันสมมูลกับ
เวกเตอร์สามตัวที่สร้าง orthonormal set
สมาชิกบนเส้นทแยงมุม
ต้องเท่ากับหนึ่งทั้งหมด ดังนั้นเป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วยแน่นอน และสมาชิก
นอกเส้นทแยงมุมต้องเป็นศูนย์
ดังนั้นเป็น orthogonal set ของเวกเตอร์
ดังนั้น U เป็นยูนิทารีก็สมมูลกับคอลัมน์ที่สร้าง orthonormal set
และนั่นต้องเป็นฐานเพราะจำนวนเวกเตอร์ในเซต ซึ่งเป็นสามในกรณีนี้ ตรงกับมิติของปริภูมิ
ที่เราทำงานอยู่ สามารถใช้เหตุผลคล้ายกันสำหรับแถวแทนคอลัมน์ เพื่อสรุปว่า U เป็น
ยูนิทารีสมมูลกับ
แถวที่สร้าง orthonormal basis
มันไม่เรียบร้อยเท่า เพราะต้องปรับเพื่อให้สังยุคเชิงซ้อน
ทำงานถูกทาง แต่แนวคิดเหมือนกัน
อีกวิธีที่ค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมาคือพิสูจน์ว่าเมทริกซ์เป็นยูนิทารีก็ต่อเมื่อทรานสโพสของมันเป็นยูนิทารี
และตรงนี้ผมหมายถึงทรานสโพส ไม่ใช่สังยุคทรานสโพส
มันค่อนข้างเห็นได้ชัดจาก
นิยามของเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี ว่าสังยุคทรานสโพส
ของเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีใดๆ เป็นยูนิทารี
แต่ก็เป็นจริงด้วยว่าทรานสโพสของเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีใดๆ เป็นยูนิทารี
อย่างไรก็ตาม เรามี
ความสมมูลระหว่างเงื่อนไขสามข้อบนเมทริกซ์จัตุรัส U ใดๆ และเราสามารถรวมความสมมูลนี้
กับข้อเท็จจริงเรื่อง
การขยาย orthonormal set เป็น orthonormal bases เพื่อหาเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
ที่ทำสิ่งที่น่าสนใจ
หรือตอบสนองความต้องการต่างๆ ที่เราอาจพบ
โดยเฉพาะ ทุกครั้งที่เรา
มี orthonormal set ของ M เวกเตอร์ จะมีเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี U อยู่เสมอ
ที่ M คอลัมน์แรกเป็นเวกเตอร์จาก orthonormal set นั้น
คอลัมน์ที่เหลือ
สามารถเติมได้เสมอเพื่อให้ได้เมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี โดยเลือกให้คอลัมน์สร้าง
orthonormal basis นี่จะเป็นข้อเท็จจริง
ที่มีประโยชน์มากสำหรับเรา
และอีกหัวข้อสำหรับ
ส่วนนี้ของบทเรียนคือแนวคิดเรื่อง projection
เมทริกซ์จัตุรัส Pi
เรียกว่าเป็น projection หรือเมทริกซ์ projection ถ้าคุณสมบัติสองข้อ
ที่ระบุไว้ตรงนี้เป็นจริงทั้งคู่
นี่คือ Pi ตัวใหญ่นะ มันเป็นตัวเลือกปกติสำหรับตัวอักษรที่ใช้แทน projection
เรามักตั้งชื่อแบบทั่วไปให้กับวัตถุเช่นเมทริกซ์ เพื่อให้จำได้ง่ายและไม่สับสน
แต่จะใช้ชื่ออะไรก็ได้ อย่างไรก็ตาม เงื่อนไขแรกคือ Pi เท่ากับสังยุคทรานสโพสของตัวมันเอง
โดยทั่วไป เมื่อเรามีเมทริกซ์ที่เท่ากับ
สังยุคทรานสโพสของมันเอง เราเรียกว่าเมทริกซ์ Hermitian
ดังนั้นเงื่อนไขแรกสามารถพูดได้อีกอย่างว่า Pi เป็น Hermitian
เงื่อนไขที่สองคือ
ถ้าเรายกกำลังสอง Pi หมายถึงคูณ Pi
กับตัวมันเอง เราได้ Pi กลับมา
ดังนั้นยกกำลังสอง Pi ไม่ได้ทำอะไรกับมัน
แนวคิดของ projection
ตามสัญชาตญาณคือ มันคล้ายกับ
การฉายภาพลงบนจอ หรือลากเส้นตั้งฉาก
ลงบนเส้น
เช่น เวลาคูณ
เวกเตอร์ด้วย projection สิ่งที่ทำคือในแง่หนึ่ง
ปล่อยส่วนหนึ่งไว้
แล้วทำให้ส่วนที่เหลือเป็นศูนย์
ดังนั้นถ้าใช้
projection ครั้งที่สอง มันไม่ได้ทำอะไรเพราะ
เราทำให้ส่วนที่ projection ทำให้เป็นศูนย์ไปแล้ว
ตัวอย่างของ projection
คือเมทริกซ์ตรงนี้ สำหรับเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย Psi ใดๆ
เราตรวจสอบว่ามันเป็นไปตาม
เงื่อนไขที่ต้องการทีละข้อได้
สำหรับข้อแรก เราคำนวณ
สังยุคทรานสโพส และนี่คือสังยุค
ทรานสโพสของผลคูณ
และเราใช้สูตรนี้ตรงนี้สำหรับสังยุคทรานสโพส
ของผลคูณเพื่อช่วย
สิ่งที่ได้คือผลคูณ
ของสังยุคทรานสโพส แต่ลำดับจะกลับกัน
นั่นเกิดขึ้นเพราะ
ส่วนของการทรานสโพส
ดังนั้นถ้าใช้สูตรนั้น เราจะได้ความเท่ากันนี้ตรงนี้ และเราก็ทำให้ง่าย
จนได้เมทริกซ์เดิมกลับมา
สังเกตนะว่าเราไม่ได้ใช้ข้อเท็จจริง
ที่ว่า Psi เป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย
ดังนั้นจริงๆ แล้ว เมทริกซ์นี้เป็น
Hermitian สำหรับเวกเตอร์ Psi ใดๆ ไม่ใช่แค่เวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย
และสำหรับข้อที่สอง เรายกกำลังสอง Pi และได้
นิพจน์นี้ตรงนี้ และมันเท่ากับ
เมทริกซ์เดิมคราวนี้
เพราะ Psi เป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย ดังนั้น inner product
ตรงนี้เท่ากับหนึ่ง และนั่นคือจุดที่สมมติฐาน
ว่า Psi เป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย
ถูกนำมาใช้
เราขยายตัวอย่างนี้ได้โดยเริ่มจาก orthonormal set
และถ้าสร้างเมทริกซ์ตรงนี้ ที่เราหาผลรวมของ projection ที่สอดคล้องกับเวกเตอร์แต่ละตัว เราก็ได้ projection
ตรงนี้บนจอ เห็นการคำนวณที่แสดงสิ่งนั้น และผมปล่อยให้ไป
ตรวจสอบเองถ้าสนใจ
และคล้ายกับ
ตัวอย่างแรก เงื่อนไขที่สองคือจุดที่ orthonormality
ของเซตถูกใช้
สิ่งที่ projection นี้ทำเมื่อ
คูณกับเวกเตอร์ คือ project เวกเตอร์นั้น
ลงบน subspace ที่ span โดยเซตของเวกเตอร์นี้
ซึ่งในแบบนามธรรมก็คือ
เหมือนลากเส้นตั้งฉากลงบน subspace นั้น และเมื่อ
อยู่ใน subspace แล้ว projection ก็ไม่ได้ทำอะไร
ดังนั้นเมทริกซ์แบบนี้เป็น
ตัวอย่างของ projection และตอนนี้เราก็ครอบคลุม
ความเป็นไปได้ทั้งหมดแล้ว
เมทริกซ์ projection ทุกตัวอยู่ในรูปนี้สำหรับ orthonormal set ที่เลือกบางอัน
เมทริกซ์ศูนย์เป็น projection ดังนั้นเราต้อง
รวมอันนั้นด้วยถ้าอยากได้ projection ทุกตัว
เพื่อให้ชัดเจน เราอนุญาต
ให้ M เท่ากับศูนย์ได้ และนั่นให้ผลรวมว่าง
ซึ่งเราตีความว่าเป็นเมทริกซ์ศูนย์
ทีนี้ เมื่อเรามี
แนวคิดเรื่อง projection แล้ว เราสามารถนิยามคลาส
ของการวัดควอนตัมที่กว้างกว่า เรียกว่า projective measurement
นี่ไม่ใช่แนวคิดทั่วไป
ที่สุดของการวัด แต่มันกว้างกว่าการวัดแบบ standard basis อย่างมาก
และจะเป็นประโยชน์มาก
ที่จะรวมมันเข้ากับคำอธิบาย
ข้อมูลควอนตัมของเรา
Projective measurement นิยามโดยเซตของ projection ใดๆ
ที่เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขที่เห็นตรงนี้ คือ projection
ทั้งหมดรวมกันได้เมทริกซ์ identity
ตรงนี้ M เป็น
จำนวนเต็มบวกอะไรก็ได้ตามใจ ตราบใดที่มันเป็น projection ทั้งหมดและเงื่อนไขนี้เป็นจริง
คอลเลกชันนั้นก็นิยาม
projective measurement
การวัดที่อธิบายโดย
คอลเลกชันแบบนี้ทำงานดังนี้ เมื่อ
วัดสถานะควอนตัม Psi ใดๆ
ก่อนอื่นเราได้ผลลัพธ์
ระหว่างหนึ่งถึง M โดย M คือจำนวน projection
สำหรับผลลัพธ์ที่เป็นไปได้แต่ละอัน K ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้ผลลัพธ์นั้นคือนอร์มแบบยูคลิด
กำลังสองของเวกเตอร์ที่ได้
จากการคูณ Psi ด้วย Pi
K ซึ่งคือ projection ตัวที่ K
เราก็เขียนปริมาณนี้
ได้ตามที่เห็นตรงนี้
ความเท่ากันนี้มาจากความสัมพันธ์ระหว่างนอร์ม
แบบยูคลิดกับ inner product ร่วมกับข้อเท็จจริง
ที่ว่า Pi K เป็น projection
จากรูปแบบที่สอง ร่วมกับเงื่อนไขที่เรามีสำหรับ projection เหล่านี้ เราเห็นได้ทันทีจากความเป็นเชิงเส้นว่าความน่าจะเป็น
จะรวมกันได้หนึ่งเสมอ
โดยจำไว้ว่า Psi
ต้องเป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย
และที่สอง สมมติว่า
เราได้ผลลัพธ์ K สถานะของระบบ
จะยุบ (collapse) เป็นสถานะควอนตัมที่ได้จากการ normalize เวกเตอร์
ที่ได้จากการ project
เราจะดูตัวอย่าง
บางอันเดี๋ยวนี้ แต่ก่อนจะทำ ขอพูดว่าเราไม่จำเป็น
ต้องกำหนดหมายเลข
ผลลัพธ์ที่เป็นไปได้ตั้งแต่หนึ่งถึง M เราเลือกชื่อหรือสัญลักษณ์อะไรก็ได้สำหรับผลลัพธ์
โดยเฉพาะ ถ้าเรามีคอลเลกชันของ projection ที่ติดป้ายด้วยสัญลักษณ์
จากเซต gamma บางเซต
และมันเป็นไปตาม
เงื่อนไขเดียวกับก่อน คือมันรวมกัน
ได้เมทริกซ์ identity เราก็มี projective measurement
ที่ทำงานเหมือนกัน
ทุกประการกับก่อนหน้า
ข้อแตกต่างเดียวตรงนี้คือเราอนุญาต
ให้ผลลัพธ์การวัดเป็นสมาชิกของเซต gamma แทนที่จะเป็นจำนวนเต็มตั้งแต่หนึ่งถึง M
สำหรับตัวอย่างแรกของ
projective measurement มาสังเกตว่า
การวัดแบบ standard basis เป็น projective measurement
ในกรณีนี้ เซตของ
ผลลัพธ์ของการวัดเหมือนกับเซตของ classical state ของระบบที่ถูกวัด
และเซตของ projection
ที่อธิบายการวัดคือคอลเลกชันตรงนี้ โดยสมมติว่า sigma คือ
classical state set
ของระบบเรา เหล่านี้เป็น projection ทั้งหมด
และถ้ารวมกัน เราได้เมทริกซ์ identity ดังนั้นเป็น projective measurement ที่ถูกต้อง
เพื่อดูว่ามันทำงานยังไง
ในรายละเอียดมากขึ้น สมมติว่าเรา
มีสถานะใดๆ ที่เขียนในรูปแบบ
ที่เห็นตรงนี้
ความน่าจะเป็นที่
การวัดจะให้ผลลัพธ์ A ตามคำอธิบาย
จากเมื่อสักครู่ คือค่าตรงนี้
ซึ่งเท่ากับ
ค่าสัมบูรณ์กำลังสองของสมาชิก
ที่สอดคล้องของเวกเตอร์ Psi ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่เราคาด
เมื่อกำหนดว่าผลลัพธ์คือ A สถานะของระบบจะกลายเป็นแบบนี้ ตามคำอธิบาย
จากเมื่อสักครู่
ถ้าเราทำให้ง่าย เราไม่ได้
สถานะที่คาดพอดี ซึ่งคือ Ket A
แต่เราได้ Ket A
คูณด้วยสเกลาร์ และโดยเฉพาะ นี่คือสเกลาร์ที่มี
ค่าสัมบูรณ์เท่ากับหนึ่ง
ดังนั้นเป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อน
บนวงกลมหนึ่งหน่วย
นี่เรียกว่า global phase และเราจะพูดถึง global phase ในอีกสักครู่ แต่สั้นๆ คือ
สถานะนี้เทียบเท่ากับ Ket A
Global phase นี้ไม่มี
ความสำคัญอะไรเลย และเราจะเห็นว่าทำไม
เมื่อเราไปถึงการพูดคุยเรื่อง global phase
ดังนั้น (ไม่ชัด) เรื่อง global phase ที่เราจะพูดในอีกสักครู่ เราเห็นว่าการวัดแบบ standard basis
เป็น projective measurement จริงๆ สำหรับอีกตัวอย่าง ซึ่งเป็นส่วนขยาย
ของตัวอย่างก่อน
ถ้าเราทำการวัด standard basis
กับระบบ X แล้วไม่ทำอะไรกับระบบ Y เหมือนที่เราพูดถึง
ในบทเรียนที่แล้ว
มันเทียบเท่ากับ
การวัดระบบ X, Y
ด้วย projective
measurement ตรงนี้
เรามี projection เหล่านี้ที่สอดคล้องกับ classical state ของ X และเราเทนเซอร์กับ identity บน Y
ซึ่งสะท้อนข้อเท็จจริงว่า
เราไม่ได้ทำอะไรกับ Y
คำอธิบายว่า
projective measurement ทำงานยังไงโดยทั่วไปบอกเรา
ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นในตัวอย่างนี้ และผมปล่อยให้ไป
ตรวจสอบว่ามันเทียบเท่ากับ
สิ่งที่เราพูดถึงในบทเรียนที่แล้วจริงๆ
ทั้งหมดนี้ดีมากเพราะ projective
measurement อธิบายได้สะอาดกว่าในแบบหนึ่ง และเราเห็นว่ามันเข้ากับ
ภาพที่กว้างกว่านี้
นี่คืออีกตัวอย่างของ
projective measurement
อันนี้คือการวัด qubit สองตัว
สำหรับการวัดนี้
เรามี projection สองตัว และดังนั้น ผลลัพธ์
ที่เป็นไปได้สองอัน คือศูนย์กับหนึ่ง
Projection นิยาม
ในรูปของสถานะ Bell ตามที่เห็นตรงนี้
Projection ตัวแรก
ลงบนปริภูมิที่ span โดยสถานะ Bell แบบสมมาตรสามตัว และ projection ตัวที่สอง
ลงบนปริภูมิหนึ่งมิติ
ที่ span โดยสถานะ Psi- ซึ่งเป็นตัวที่ต้านสมมาตร หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ
ตัวที่ถูกคูณ
ด้วยเครื่องหมายลบถ้าเรา
ทำการดำเนินการ swap บน qubit สองตัว
เราจะเห็นทีหลังในซีรีส์ว่าทำไมนี่เป็นการวัดที่น่าสนใจ
ตอนนี้ มันแค่ตัวอย่าง
ที่เชื่อมโยงกับสิ่งที่เราเห็นมาก่อน
ซึ่งคือ Bell basis
ข้อสังเกตสุดท้ายเรื่อง projective measurement คือทุกครั้งที่มี
projective measurement เราสามารถ implement การวัดนั้นได้เสมอ
โดยใช้การดำเนินการยูนิทารีกับ
การวัดแบบ standard basis
สำหรับตัวอย่างนี้ของ
การวัดเช่น เราสามารถสร้าง quantum circuit ที่ implement การวัด
ตามที่เห็นตรงนี้
ลองจินตนาการว่า qubit
สองตัวบนคือ qubit ที่เราวัดด้วย
projective measurement นี้ และสิ่งที่เราทำได้คือ
เพิ่ม qubit ใหม่
ที่เริ่มต้น initialized
เป็นสถานะศูนย์ เราทำ Hadamard gate
ตามด้วย Fredkin gate ตามด้วย Hadamard gate อีกตัว
และถ้าเราวัด qubit ล่างนี้ด้วยการวัดแบบ standard basis ผลจะเหมือนกันทุกประการกับถ้าเราวัด qubit สองตัวบน
ด้วย projective
measurement จากตัวอย่างนี้
เราจะได้ความน่าจะเป็นเหมือนกันสำหรับผลลัพธ์ทั้งสอง และผลกระทบที่การวัดมีต่อ qubit สองตัวบน
ก็จะเหมือนกัน
นั่นไม่ชัดเจนเลย ต้องมีการวิเคราะห์จึงจะเห็น และการวิเคราะห์นั้นไม่ได้แสดงไว้ตรงนี้
อย่างที่บอกไปแล้ว เราจะดูการวัดนี้
อย่างละเอียดมากขึ้นในบทเรียนหลัง และตอนนี้
มันแค่เป็นตัวอย่าง
ประเด็นสำคัญที่ต้องจำไว้คือ สิ่งแบบ
นี้เป็นไปได้เสมอสำหรับ projective measurement ใดๆ ดังนั้นเราไม่ได้
ความสามารถเพิ่มเติมจริงๆ
จากการแนะนำ projective measurement แต่มันเป็นแนวคิดที่มีประโยชน์มาก และเรามักจะพูดถึง
projective measurement
เมื่อเราดำเนินต่อในซีรีส์ ส่วนสุดท้ายของบทเรียนนี้เป็นเรื่องข้อจำกัดที่สำคัญบางอย่าง
ของข้อมูลควอนตัม
และสิ่งที่เราทำได้ด้วย quantum circuit
ข้อจำกัดแรก ซึ่งอาจไม่ใช่ข้อจำกัดเท่ากับเป็นความเสื่อม (degeneracy) เกี่ยวข้องกับเรื่อง global phase
ที่พูดถึงเมื่อสักครู่ นี่คือนิยามของสิ่งที่เราหมายถึงเมื่อพูดถึง global phase
ถ้าเรามีเวกเตอร์สถานะ
ควอนตัมสองตัว Psi และ Phi ที่ตัวหนึ่ง
เท่ากับอีกตัวคูณด้วยจำนวนเชิงซ้อน alpha บางตัว
เราก็บอกว่าสถานะทั้งสอง
ต่างกันด้วย global phase หรืออีกอย่างคือเทียบเท่ากันโดยไม่นับ global phase
สังเกตว่าเพราะเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมมีนอร์มแบบยูคลิดเท่ากับหนึ่ง ทางเดียวที่สมการนี้
จะเป็นจริงได้
คือถ้าค่าสัมบูรณ์
ของจำนวนเชิงซ้อนนี้เท่ากับหนึ่ง ดังนั้น alpha
ต้องอยู่บนวงกลมหนึ่งหน่วย
ลองจินตนาการว่าเรามี
สถานะควอนตัมสองสถานะแบบนี้ที่ต่างกันด้วย global phase และสมมติว่าเราวัดสถานะ Phi
ด้วยการวัดแบบ standard basis
ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้ผลลัพธ์ A ใดๆ ให้โดยนิพจน์ตรงนี้ และถ้าเราแทน
alpha คูณ Psi แทน Phi
ซึ่งทำได้เพราะเรา
สมมติว่ามันเท่ากัน เราก็ได้ความน่าจะเป็นนี้
และถ้าเราทำให้ง่ายโดยใช้ข้อเท็จจริงว่า alpha อยู่บน
วงกลมหนึ่งหน่วยของจำนวนเชิงซ้อน เราก็ได้ความน่าจะเป็นนี้
จำไว้ว่านี่คือความน่าจะเป็นที่การวัด Phi ให้ผลลัพธ์ A แต่ตอนนี้เราเห็นว่า
นี่เหมือนกันทุกประการกับความน่าจะเป็นที่การวัด
Psi ให้ผลลัพธ์ A
ดังนั้นไม่มีความ
แตกต่างอะไรเลยในความน่าจะเป็นของผลลัพธ์ต่างๆ สำหรับสถานะทั้งสอง
เหตุผลคล้ายกันบอกเราโดยทั่วไปกว่าว่า สำหรับ projective measurement ใดๆ ความน่าจะเป็นก็เหมือนกัน
ดังนั้นจากการวัด เราไม่สามารถ
แยกความแตกต่างระหว่างสถานะสองสถานะที่
ต่างกันด้วย global phase ได้ แม้ในเชิงสถิติ
สุดท้าย ถ้าเราใช้การดำเนินการ
ยูนิทารีใดๆ กับสถานะ Phi จากการแทนค่า สิ่งที่จะได้คือ
จำนวนเชิงซ้อน alpha ตัวเดิม
คูณกับสิ่งที่จะได้จากการใช้การดำเนินการยูนิทารี
เดียวกันกับสถานะ Psi
ดังนั้นสถานะทั้งสองจะยังคง
ต่างกันด้วย global phase
สรุปคือสถานะทั้งสองแยกแยะไม่ได้เลย ดังนั้นไม่มีความแตกต่าง
จริงๆ ระหว่างมัน
ในแง่ของสิ่งที่เรา
อาจเรียนรู้จากมันจากการดำเนินการ
ยูนิทารีและการวัด และด้วยเหตุนี้
เราถือว่าสถานะ
ทั้งสองเทียบเท่ากัน หรือถ้าชอบ ว่ามันเป็นแค่การแทนเวกเตอร์สองแบบที่อาจต่างกัน
ของสถานะควอนตัม
เดียวกัน
อย่างที่พูดตอน
เริ่มพูดคุย มันเป็นความเสื่อมพื้นฐาน
ในวิธีที่สถานะควอนตัมถูกอธิบายด้วยเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
อย่างไรก็ตาม สิ่งที่นี่หมายถึงคือเราสามารถ
แค่ข้าม global phase ไป เหมือนที่เราทำจริงๆ เมื่อเราอธิบายการวัดแบบ
standard basis
ว่าเป็น projective measurement อย่างไรก็ตาม ความเสื่อม (degeneracy) นี้เกิดขึ้นแค่ในคำอธิบายแบบง่าย
ของข้อมูลควอนตัม
เมื่อเราอธิบายสถานะ
ควอนตัมด้วย density matrix ซึ่งเราจะทำใน
หน่วยที่สามของซีรีส์ เราจะมีการแทน
เมทริกซ์ที่ไม่ซ้ำ
สำหรับสถานะควอนตัมทุกสถานะ ปัญหา global phase
ไม่เกิดขึ้นในคำอธิบายทั่วไป
ของข้อมูลควอนตัม
มันเป็นอีกแง่ที่น่าสนใจ
ของคำอธิบายทั่วไปของข้อมูลควอนตัม
ที่ผมพูดถึงเรื่อยมา แต่ถึงอย่างไร global
phase จะไม่รบกวนเรา
เพราะเราแค่ใช้สิทธิ์
ที่จะข้ามมันไปได้
นี่คือตัวอย่างสั้นๆ
เพื่อให้แน่ใจว่าแนวคิดเรื่อง global phase ชัดเจน
ถ้าเรามีสถานะลบ และลบหนึ่งคูณสถานะลบ สถานะทั้งสอง
ต่างกันด้วย global phase และโดยเฉพาะ
alpha เท่ากับลบหนึ่ง
อีกด้านหนึ่ง ถ้าเรามีสถานะบวกและสถานะลบ เราไม่มีสถานะสองสถานะ
ที่ต่างกันด้วย global phase
พวกมันเป็นเวกเตอร์ orthogonal ดังนั้นเป็นอิสระเชิงเส้น
การพูดว่าเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมสองตัวต่างกันด้วย global phase
เทียบเท่ากับการพูดว่าเวกเตอร์ไม่เป็นอิสระเชิงเส้น
ดังนั้นเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้แน่นอน
ไม่ต่างกันด้วย global phase
มันเป็นจริงว่าความแตกต่างเดียวคือ
เครื่องหมายบวกนี้กลายเป็นเครื่องหมายลบนี้ แต่นั่นคือสิ่งที่เราเรียกว่า
relative phase difference
นั่นต่างจาก global phase เพราะเราไม่ได้
คูณทั้งเวกเตอร์ด้วยจำนวนเชิงซ้อน
และนี่สอดคล้องกับข้อเท็จจริงว่าเราสามารถแยกความแตกต่าง
ระหว่างสถานะเหล่านี้ได้ โดยเฉพาะ ถ้าเรา
ใช้ Hadamard operation
แล้ววัด เราจะเห็นศูนย์ถ้า
สถานะเป็นสถานะบวก และหนึ่งถ้าสถานะเป็นสถานะลบ
ข้อจำกัดถัดไปของข้อมูลควอนตัมที่เราจะเห็นในบทเรียนนี้
คือทฤษฎีบท no-cloning
นี่คือข้อความหนึ่งของ
ทฤษฎีบท no-cloning และข้อความ
เฉพาะนี้ค่อนข้างเป็นรูปธรรมและเจาะจง
ซึ่งจะทำให้พูดถึงง่ายขึ้น มีวิธีอื่นที่ทั่วไปกว่าในการระบุทฤษฎีบท no-cloning
แต่เราจะโฟกัสที่อันนี้ก่อน
เราสมมติว่ามีระบบ X กับ Y สองระบบที่มี classical state set เหมือนกัน
ซึ่งประกอบด้วย
จำนวนเต็มตั้งแต่ศูนย์ถึง D-1 โดย D อย่างน้อยสอง
ไม่สำคัญจริงๆ ว่า classical state ชื่ออะไร แต่การเลือกชื่อเหล่านี้จะช่วยให้ง่ายขึ้น
สิ่งที่สำคัญที่สุด
ตรงนี้คือต้องมี classical
state อย่างน้อยสองสถานะ พูดอีกอย่างคือ เราไม่ต้อง
กังวลเรื่องกรณีเล็กน้อยที่ไม่น่าสนใจ
ที่เรามี classical state แค่ตัวเดียว
สิ่งที่ทฤษฎีบทบอกคือไม่มีการดำเนินการยูนิทารี U ที่เราใช้กับ X, Y เพื่อที่ว่าถ้าเรา initialize
Y เป็นสถานะศูนย์
เราจะคัดลอกหรือโคลน
สถานะควอนตัมใดๆ ของ X ได้อย่างมีประสิทธิผล
ถ้าเราดูนิพจน์
ตรงนี้แยกต่างหาก มันบอกว่าสำหรับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม Psi ของ X ใดๆ
การใช้ U กับ Psi เทนเซอร์
กับสถานะศูนย์ ให้เรา Psi เทนเซอร์ Psi หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือสำเนา
อิสระสองชุดของ Psi
นั่นคือสิ่งที่จะหมายถึงถ้าเราโคลนสถานะ
ควอนตัมได้ และทฤษฎีบทบอกว่ามันเป็นไปไม่ได้
เราคิดเรื่องนี้ได้
ในรูปของ circuit และทฤษฎีบทบอกว่า
เราจะไม่มีทางหา gate หรือ circuit
ที่ทำงานตามที่เห็นตรงนี้
ที่สำเนาหนึ่งของสถานะ Psi เข้ามาพร้อมกับชุดของ
qubit ที่ initialized แล้วสำเนาสองชุดของ Psi ถูกผลิตออกมา
ทำได้สำหรับสถานะ Psi
ที่เลือกบางตัว แต่ไม่มีทางหา
circuit ที่ทำงานแบบนี้สำหรับสถานะควอนตัม Psi ทุกตัว
และนั่นคือสิ่งที่ทฤษฎีบทบอก
ค่อนข้างง่ายที่จะพิสูจน์
ทฤษฎีบทนี้ จริงๆ แล้วมันเป็นเพราะ transformation ที่เรา
ต้องการนั้นไม่ใช่แบบเชิงเส้น
แต่การดำเนินการยูนิทารีเป็น
เชิงเส้น ดังนั้นมันใช้ไม่ได้
นี่คือเหตุผลที่ละเอียดขึ้นอีกหน่อย
สมมติว่าเรามีการดำเนินการยูนิทารี U ที่โคลน standard basis
state Ket 0 กับ Ket หนึ่ง
เรารู้ว่า classical
state ศูนย์กับหนึ่งต้องอยู่ใน classical state set ของเราเพราะ D อย่างน้อยสอง
แต่นี่หมายความว่าจากความเป็นเชิงเส้น
ถ้า X อยู่ในสถานะบวก ซึ่งเราเขียนได้แบบนี้
ผลลัพธ์ก็คือผลรวมเชิงเส้นของสถานะสองสถานะตรงนี้
อย่างไรก็ตาม นั่นไม่ใช่พฤติกรรมที่ถูกต้อง ข้อกำหนดของ U คือ
U โคลนสถานะบวก
หมายความว่าต้อง
เป็นไปตามสมการตรงนี้
สถานะทั้งสองไม่
เหมือนกัน ดังนั้นมันใช้ไม่ได้ และนั่นก็คือทั้งหมด
แค่ข้อสังเกตเพิ่มเติม
เกี่ยวกับทฤษฎีบท no-cloning
อันแรก ข้อความนี้ของ
ทฤษฎีบท no-cloning เป็นแบบเด็ดขาดในแง่หนึ่ง
มันแค่บอกว่าการดำเนินการยูนิทารี U ที่ทำงานแบบ
นี้พอดีนั้นไม่มีอยู่
ดังนั้นอาจถามว่า
มีการดำเนินการยูนิทารี U ที่
ทำสิ่งนี้โดยประมาณหรือเปล่า ในแง่ของวิธีอธิบาย
การประมาณต่อข้อความนั้น มีแนวคิด
ของการประมาณที่ต่างกันที่เราอาจสนใจ
และเราจะเห็นสองสามแบบ
ในหน่วยที่สามของซีรีส์ แต่สำหรับแนวคิด
การประมาณที่ต่างกันเหล่านี้
มีข้อความเชิงปริมาณ
ของทฤษฎีบท no-cloning ที่จำกัดอย่างมากว่าเราจะโคลนโดยประมาณได้ดีแค่ไหน
ข้อสังเกตที่สองคือ การคัดลอกหรือโคลน standard basis state ทำ
ได้แน่นอน
ตัวอย่างเช่น Controlled NOT gate คัดลอก standard basis state ของ qubit
นี่ไม่ขัดแย้งกับ
ทฤษฎีบท no-cloning ประเด็นคือการโคลนในความหมายของทฤษฎีบท no-cloning ต้องการ
ให้มันทำงานไม่ใช่แค่
กับ standard basis state
แต่กับสถานะทั้งหมด
Controlled NOT gate
แน่นอนไม่ได้โคลนสถานะบวกเช่น
และสุดท้าย ก็ควรบอกว่ามีทฤษฎีบท no-cloning สำหรับ
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นด้วย
แค่ไม่ใช่สิ่งที่
คนพูดถึงหรือสนใจ
ถ้าใครสุ่ม
เลือกบิตสักบิต โดยวิธีกำหนด
ความน่าจะเป็นให้กับสองค่าแบบใดก็ได้ แล้วส่ง
บิตนั้นให้เรา
แน่นอนไม่มีทางที่จะได้ตัวอย่างอิสระสองชุด
ของบิตสุ่มนั้น
เราแค่ไม่รู้ว่า
ความน่าจะเป็นคืออะไร
สามารถคัดลอกบิตได้ เหมือนกับ Controlled NOT
คัดลอก standard basis state แต่นั่นไม่เหมือนกับการโคลนสถานะความน่าจะเป็น
เราแค่ไม่มีข้อมูลเพียงพอ
ที่จะทำ บิตสุ่มที่ได้มาไม่ได้บอกว่า
ความน่าจะเป็นคืออะไร
มันเป็นแค่บิต
ความเป็นไปไม่ได้ของการโคลน
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นตามมาจากเหตุผลเดียวกันกับในกรณีควอนตัม
การโคลนเป็นกระบวนการไม่เชิงเส้น ในขณะที่การดำเนินการความน่าจะเป็น เหมือนกับการดำเนินการยูนิทารี เป็นเชิงเส้น
อย่างไรก็ตาม ไม่น่าแปลกใจ
ที่เราโคลนสถานะความน่าจะเป็นไม่ได้ และ
มันก็ไม่น่าสนใจเท่ากับข้อเท็จจริงว่าเราโคลน
สถานะควอนตัมไม่ได้
แต่ประเด็นคือแค่สังเกตว่านี่ไม่ใช่ปรากฏการณ์ที่
เกิดเฉพาะกับควอนตัม
ข้อจำกัดสุดท้าย
ของข้อมูลควอนตัมที่เราจะพูดถึงในบทเรียนนี้คือ มันเป็นไปไม่ได้ที่จะ
แยกแยะอย่างสมบูรณ์แบบ
สถานะควอนตัมสองสถานะที่ไม่ orthogonal
อีกวิธีพูดคือ
ถ้าสถานะควอนตัมสองสถานะสามารถถูกแยกแยะได้อย่างสมบูรณ์แบบ มันต้อง orthogonal
สิ่งที่เราหมายถึงเมื่อพูดถึง
การแยกแยะอย่างสมบูรณ์แบบของสถานะควอนตัม Psi กับ Phi สองสถานะ คือมีวิธี
บอกมันออกจากกัน
โดยไม่มีโอกาสผิดพลาด
ในรูปของ quantum circuit model เราแสดงสิ่งนี้ได้ตามที่
เห็นตรงนี้บนจอ
เรามีการดำเนินการยูนิทารี U บางอัน ซึ่งอาจ implement
เป็น quantum circuit หรือเราก็คิดถึง U แบบนามธรรม
เป็นการดำเนินการยูนิทารี
และสำหรับอินพุต U รับสถานะ Psi หรือสถานะ Phi
พร้อมกับ qubit ที่ initialized กลุ่มหนึ่ง ซึ่งคิดว่าเป็น qubit พื้นที่ทำงานที่ช่วยใน
กระบวนการแยกแยะ
หลังจากใช้ U แล้ว qubit บนถูกวัดด้วยการวัดแบบ standard basis และนี่คือส่วน
การแยกแยะอย่างสมบูรณ์แบบ
ถ้าสถานะอินพุตเป็น Psi การวัดต้อง
ให้ผลลัพธ์ศูนย์ 100% ของเวลา และถ้า
สถานะอินพุตเป็น Phi
การวัดต้อง
ให้ผลลัพธ์หนึ่ง อีกครั้งด้วยโอกาส 100%
ไม่สำคัญว่า
สถานะของ qubit อื่นๆ จะเป็นอะไรหลังจากใช้ U
สิ่งที่สำคัญคือบิตเดียวนี้ที่ได้จากการวัด เพราะนั่นคือบิตที่บอกเราว่าเราเริ่มด้วยสถานะไหนในสองสถานะ
สำหรับสถานะ Psi กับ Phi ที่เลือกบางอย่าง จะเป็นไปได้ที่จะทำการแยกแยะอย่างสมบูรณ์แบบแบบ
นี้ และสำหรับบางอย่างก็ไม่ได้
และสิ่งที่เราจะสังเกตคือ
ถ้ามันเป็นไปได้ที่จะทำสิ่งนี้ Psi กับ Phi ต้อง
เป็นสถานะ orthogonal
และนั่นหมายความว่าถ้า Phi กับ
Psi ไม่ orthogonal เราแยกแยะมันอย่างสมบูรณ์แบบไม่ได้
มาดูกันว่าทำไมการแยกแยะอย่างสมบูรณ์แบบบ่งบอก orthogonality
เราจะเริ่มด้วยเขียนสมการสองสมการที่แสดงสิ่งที่
ไดอะแกรมสองอันนี้แสดง
ถ้าเราคิดถึงสถานะควอนตัมที่ได้หลังจากใช้ U กับ
qubit ที่ initialized กลุ่มหนึ่งพร้อมกับสถานะ Psi
เราเห็นว่ามันต้อง
อยู่ในรูปตรงนี้ โดย Pi ศูนย์เป็นเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมบางตัวที่แทนสถานะ
ของ qubit ทั้งหมดเหล่านี้
ยกเว้นตัวบน เราไม่มีข้อมูล
เกี่ยวกับสถานะควอนตัม Pi ศูนย์นี้ มันเป็นอะไรก็ได้
แต่เรารู้ว่าสถานะ
ทั้งหมดต้องดูแบบนี้ เพราะนั่นเป็น
ทางเดียวที่การวัดจะรับประกันว่าให้
ผลลัพธ์ศูนย์ 100% ของเวลา
และเรามีสมการ
ที่คล้ายกันสำหรับอันที่สอง
คราวนี้ qubit บน
ต้องอยู่ในสถานะหนึ่ง และคล้ายกับ Pi ศูนย์
สถานะ Pi หนึ่งเป็นอะไรก็ได้
และนอกจากไม่มี
ข้อมูลเกี่ยวกับ Pi หนึ่ง เราก็ไม่รู้อะไรเลย
เกี่ยวกับความสัมพันธ์ระหว่าง Pi ศูนย์กับ Pi หนึ่ง
เท่าที่เรารู้ มันเป็นแค่สถานะ
ควอนตัมใดๆ สองสถานะ
สิ่งที่เราทำต่อได้คือ
คูณทั้งสองข้างของสมการเหล่านี้
ทั้งสองข้างด้วย U dagger หมายถึงสังยุคทรานสโพสของ U
และถ้าทำแบบนั้น เราจะได้สมการสองอัน
ที่เห็นตรงนี้
เราใช้ข้อเท็จจริงว่า U dagger คูณ U คือเมทริกซ์ identity
นั่นคือเหตุผลที่ไม่เห็น U หรือ U dagger ทางซ้ายของสมการทั้งสอง
และตอนนี้เราพิจารณา inner product ระหว่าง Psi กับ Phi ได้
มันเหมือนกับ inner
product ของ Psi กับ Phi คูณกับ inner
product ของสถานะ L ศูนย์กับตัวมันเอง
เพราะ inner product ของ
สถานะใดๆ กับตัวมันเองเป็นหนึ่ง และรวมถึงสถานะ L ศูนย์ด้วย
และตอนนี้ถ้าดูสมการสองอัน เราเห็นว่านิพจน์ตรงนี้เท่ากับ inner product ของเวกเตอร์
ที่แทนด้วยสมการสองอัน และโดยเฉพาะมันเป็น inner product ระหว่างข้างซ้าย
ของสมการเหล่านี้
ดังนั้นเราก็แสดง
inner product นี้เป็น inner product ของเวกเตอร์ที่แทนด้วยข้าง
ขวาของสมการเหล่านี้ได้เช่นกัน
เพราะข้างซ้าย
เท่ากับข้างขวาสำหรับทั้งสองสมการ
ดังนั้นเราได้นิพจน์ตรงนี้ ซึ่งคือ inner product
ของข้างขวาทั้งสองของสมการ หรือกล่าวอีกอย่าง
คือสังยุคทรานสโพสของตัวแรกคูณกับตัวที่สอง
U คูณ U dagger เท่ากับ
เมทริกซ์ identity เพราะ U เป็นยูนิทารี ดังนั้นมันหายไป
และเราทำให้ง่ายอีกนิดหน่อยเพื่อให้ได้ผลคูณของ
inner product เหล่านี้
จำไว้ว่าเราไม่รู้อะไรเกี่ยวกับความสัมพันธ์
ระหว่าง Pi ศูนย์กับ Pi หนึ่ง ดังนั้นเราไม่รู้ว่า
inner product ของมันเป็นเท่าไหร่
นั่นเป็นปริศนาสำหรับเรา แต่ไม่ว่ามันจะเป็นอะไร เรากำลังคูณมันด้วย inner product ของ Ket 0 กับ Ket หนึ่ง ซึ่งเป็นศูนย์
ดังนั้นผลลัพธ์สุดท้ายคือ
เราได้ค่าศูนย์ แต่นั่นคือสิ่งที่เราอยากแสดง inner product ระหว่าง
Psi กับ Phi เท่ากับศูนย์
ดังนั้นสถานะทั้งสอง orthogonal กัน
ดังนั้นอย่าพยายาม
แยกแยะสถานะควอนตัมสองสถานะที่ไม่ orthogonal
อย่างสมบูรณ์แบบ มันทำไม่ได้
มีบทกลับของ
ข้อความที่เราเพิ่งพิสูจน์ ซึ่งก็คือสถานะควอนตัม orthogonal สามารถถูกแยกแยะอย่างสมบูรณ์แบบได้เสมอ
และนี่ไม่ยากที่จะ
เห็นถ้าเราใช้ข้อเท็จจริงที่พูดถึงก่อนหน้าในบทเรียน
โดยเฉพาะ ถ้า Psi กับ
Phi เป็นสถานะ orthogonal สิ่งหนึ่งที่ทำได้คือเลือกเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี U ใดๆ
ที่สองคอลัมน์แรก
เป็นสถานะทั้งสอง
เรารู้ว่ามันเป็นไป
ได้เสมอที่จะทำสิ่งนี้ และไม่สำคัญ
สำหรับงานนี้ว่าเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีถูกเลือกอย่างไร
สิ่งที่สำคัญคือนี่คือสองคอลัมน์แรก
เราไม่ต้องใช้ qubit เพิ่ม ถ้าเราแค่ใช้ U กับ
สถานะที่เป็นไปได้สองสถานะ เราก็จะได้
ผลลัพธ์ที่เป็นไปได้สองแบบนี้
และถ้าเราวัด qubit บนสุด ซึ่งจำไว้ว่าคือ qubit ขวาสุด เราจะได้ศูนย์หรือหนึ่ง
ขึ้นอยู่กับว่าเราเริ่มจากสถานะไหน
อีกทางเลือก เราพิจารณา
projective measurement ที่มีผลลัพธ์ศูนย์กับหนึ่ง
ที่นิยามตามที่เห็นตรงนี้
ในกรณีนี้ การวัด
จริงๆ ขึ้นอยู่กับแค่ Psi
การวัดนี้แยกแยะ
Psi จากสถานะใดๆ ที่ orthogonal กับ Psi ได้อย่างสมบูรณ์แบบ
ถ้าเราวัด Psi ด้วย projective measurement นี้ เราจะได้ผลลัพธ์
ศูนย์ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นหนึ่ง ตามที่สมการเหล่านี้แสดง
และสำหรับสถานะ Phi ใดๆ
ที่ orthogonal กับ Psi เราจะได้ผลลัพธ์
หนึ่งด้วยความน่าจะเป็นหนึ่ง
ผมจะไม่ลงรายละเอียด
ของการคำนวณเหล่านี้ แต่ถ้าสนใจ ผมแนะนำให้ลง
รายละเอียดด้วยตัวเอง
และนั่นคือจบบทเรียนที่สาม เราครอบคลุมเนื้อหา
เยอะมากในบทเรียนนี้ รวมถึง quantum circuit
inner product และ orthonormality, projection และ projective measurement, ข้อเท็จจริงว่า global phase ไม่มีผล
ทฤษฎีบท no-cloning และข้อเท็จจริงว่าสถานะที่ไม่ orthogonal ไม่สามารถถูกแยกแยะได้อย่างสมบูรณ์แบบ ในขณะที่สถานะ orthogonal ทำได้
หวังว่าจะมาร่วมกันใน
บทเรียนที่สี่เร็วๆ นี้ ซึ่งเป็นบทเรียนสุดท้ายใน
หน่วยแรกของซีรีส์
ในบทเรียนที่สี่ เราจะพูดถึง
ตัวอย่างที่สำคัญมากสามอัน คือ teleportation, superdense coding,
และอสมการ CHSH หรือเกม CHSH ตามที่บางทีเรียกกัน
ลาก่อนจนกว่าจะถึงตอนนั้น